Lagos maybe a toy but it's not really
for kids you'll need a driver's license
to play with this creation this is the
world's first working car made almost
entirely from Legos more than a half a
million pieces were used and that's
1,100 pounds of plastic flaps
I have made some pretty cool Lego models
in my time but nothing as awesome as
this over five million people online
watch this clip of the cars maiden
voyage it's the work of Steve Sammartino
and Raoul Reuter who tore up the
instruction manual and became master
builder
took a trip down under to meet Steve
asked about the inspiration for such an
awesome project well it came from an
idea with RAL who I did it with he saw a
tiny Lego engine on YouTube and he
convinced me that he could build a giant
one so the project took 12 months in
building and about six months in
planning the build the car was built in
Romania and then we shipped the car to
Australia a lot of it fell apart in that
transporting process and then we've
rebuilt it here in Australia and did all
the test driving and filming of it
comfort is not one of its strong points
the steering wheel is very comfortable
to hold the seats are horrible it's a
bit of a bumpy ride but hey it's not
every day you can drive a car down the
road that's actually made of Lego it is
a huge achievement but the best part is
if they get bored with the car they
could always just build something else